I just got this is news of the
collection you know I'm tracking my
steps trying to be a sex ring twice well
you can't work out on the rulers that's
just ridiculous so I won't have watch we
can answer text you can talk to people
you can't do that on the rule is relax
step your game up what up is mustard and
this is on the rocks or GQ my watches
this is my forget rolex presidential
this is by these 60 it gets all down the
middle and all baguettes in the face and
i got this because it's a song to get
these in the face of them i'll i'll just
knew when we shot the video i don't want
to not beat on the wall to get these in
the face and I seen Metro I had the
white one you know it's just like I
gotta get this one this is a watch out
where like every day
besides my hyper watch this is my
regular presidential with the black face
I feel like everybody should definitely
invest in these because you don't really
lose value only if you go in the store
buy a brand new is probably fifty six
fifty I don't know you look at those
prices like that this right here is one
of my favorites I had this for a while
just for a long time this is a ap
skeleton and this probably go for like
120,000 right now I love a p/e so I'm
definitely definitely getting another
one of these I really like ApS I like
Richards but I can't figure out which
one I'll only get at this point the one
that was gonna get future got it and
it's like so just set me back when I had
a conversation why did you get that
watch
what does the start for like the washes
is because you know trains that you know
really get as much as you would think
back like that but the watches think I
know what that value it looks I can't
tell you that because everybody's been
going a little crazy on the watches and
I have to keep my ideas to myself at
this point because it's getting Rick
this honor with these watches I know
that Metro has an impressive watch
collection and I got to do some catching
up
it's my baby the chain is not here I do
still have the chain it's a Frank on the
super long who got some threes the were
like well Shannon I got this in like
maybe 2013 this was either 50 to 70 I
don't even know I spent all my money on
it though
I don't have any money I don't know what
I was thinking or what I got it from I
see fish Oh
canary yellow with the green blue
actually opens there were known for
years I was actually right on time
no clear story about this chain so I was
flying a helicopter in my house like
blue control helicopters and I flew it
up to the top and it hit the sprinkler
in the house so it's just water
splashing all over the house and like my
house is flat so I picked up all my and
I had that was valuable I think my jury
being my girl we leave my son so I check
in the hotel on I'm late late night I
pull up to that Lake get out the car I
leave this in the middle console for
whatever reason I don't know we went
upstairs went to sleep when I woke back
up in the morning we went downstairs to
get the car and guess what the car is
gone so it wasn't violated some drunk
car this dumbass takes everything out
the car except this chain and left the
surprise you dick it so you know it's my
baby who's been around for
[Music]
see how heavy that is yeah it's pretty
crazy right this is my second piece and
I got this one
I see fresh as well it's a big Michigan
him and it's like DJ mustard under it I
just always wanted the Michigan because
my name is my student I just thought it
would be fire next edition and I used to
wear them together and it's just be
extra cost a little more than this one
so maybe 70,000 60,000 okay so that was
like I see fresh days and this
definitely I see fresh and I started
getting my jury done by Elliott in New
York and we brew relationship I've seen
young thug's wire sale chain I like the
setting of the diamonds on that and at
that time my settings was like far apart
diamonds I guess this is a different
setting insulator so I had earlier
duties the same way and you know now all
I have is these feathers and got the
enamel on the back I got the white one
to ten summers is my record label how I
came up with ten summers I think I heard
Rick Ross say I'm gonna be on for the
next ten summers and my birthday and my
sister's birthday is the fifth so my
sisters is September 5th - June 5th my
mom's birthday is March 10th so that
makes ten tens just doing my lucky
number for a long time I was like man if
every artist that I signed could be
successful for ten summers I would make
perfect sense
[Music]
this is my first big piece from Ellie I
remember he was like man we got to do
some stage this is a Cuban but these are
the big stones and then I want big
stones all the way around here and all
the details even in the size ear stones
and they're just super iced out you know
I'm saying at this time I don't think a
lot of people is doing the big stones so
I kind of got on it a little early this
is like 120 or something like that
because every time was like you might
pay a lot but you're gonna get what you
pay for it always be right
my diamonds hit better than everybody so
it's just obvious like Jenin must have
be it's like rich crazy I got this from
Elliot as well it's a 400 Sommers Cheney
and yg label connected they just
represent me and watching Joe have a ten
summers chain like this I used to wear
this a lot I got another one that was
gold and they said 400 summers and I
gave that to yg for Christmas say 400
summers 400 is my brand and label ten
summers is mustard
this is a different jeweler this is
wifey jury and living different Atlanta
and I wanted a chain like qcp and I was
just like just give me the same or just
put of ten perfect ten just wanted to
album chain and it's all baguettes and
their size and here the gets two years
just like 70,000 I just thought it was
fire see girlfriend Johnny dang I had
like three of these but I lost two so
I'm just going on I use it's the most
comfortable for me anyway other ones I
lost but it is it's like when I just
want to be extra doubt and just want to
wear on top of I'm on stage there's a
lot only wear it all the time I got nice
to you so this is actually Meeks chain
he gave me this to wear for a video I
just never returned it back to upset me
I got your chain you see it on a tour
and I get you there let me keep it shiny
this week's true yeah so something made
Sean make this you know it says TMC RFP
knit I say shines above he made these
and then I got this chain from Elliott
and this chain chain fire like eighty
thousand senator
it's like sixty pointers and seventy
pointers mix so you can see the Diamonds
get bigger as you go down
so barely account will just make you pay
more moved it
I just got this I just got this like two
days ago this is like my little bro
his name is officially passed away this
year but I don't hear it says long with
DJ official tennis so much for life
haunting some risk and shine did this
change to twenty five point and chain
and this was fun
he can literally wear these together and
they look crazy at the time this was
inspired by the Flatbush zombies I seen
earlier do it shame for them and I think
it says zombies and it was like green
enamel and I was like that's so far you
got to give me the mustard I got this
one and I got this nice to wear them
together
this is far this is like 20,000 they
really have you - this is my
championship test I'm wearing Elliott
made this super boat in it stands on the
side stay ten summers right here stay
records right here this is about insect
$30,000 this was about 20 this is this I
don't know where I say I think Elliot
just posted it and I wanted it back it's
like big stones around here Michael
probably around here one of the diamonds
missing because I worried about these
two pink ears I think I paid ten
thousand each for these I wear like this
really cool
now to the new this is this ketchup
chasing mustard - ketchup bottle chasing
the most of our local I'm writing
mustard and everybody else - ketchup
that was the concept line say ten
summers right here and it's like four
layers so you see you've got these big
stones right here just say you don't
want to Elliot on the back and then just
call it a green light peeps so Elliot
giving the green light don't matter what
the cost is he's going all the way and
you definitely all the way the chain -
this is not here because Elliot is
fixing it so I can connect myself but
nobody else has the link the whole setup
this between other things like sixteen
best chain in the game right now
next to tape off rocky this is my game
changer
yeah got me this is one of the Cubans
that came with it this is really extra
doubt when you warm together
I wore my feet all right so this to me
was worth like t1000 and his have you
finish a link that nobody has say
whether you got a copyrighted so you
jewelers can't take my this is the
definition of a green light peach thing
you want a green light piece for these
nugget money together because green
light I mean he doesn't stop and get
pretty expensive
I wear this myself a lot any given day
is twenty thousand said me
[Music]